[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه والحلقه السابقه
المؤرخ البارز ان التاريخ الجديد المتعلق
بدوله الاحتلال يفسره عاملا احدهما اجتياح
الاسرائيلي للبنان عام 82 التي كانت حربا
اختياريه على العكس من الحروب السابقه
التي سوقت لها اسرائيل باعتبارها حروبا
اجبرت عليها اما العامل الاخر فكان الكشف
عن الوثائق الرسميه لدوله الاحتلال بعد ان
ظلت طي الاقبيه والكتمان طيله 30 عاما
بموجب قانون يمنعوا الكشف عنها الا بعد
انقضاء هذه المده هذان العام العام برايك
شكل اساسا لنسف كل الروايات التي قدمت
خلال العقود الممتده منذ اعلان قيام
الدوله الاحتلال وحتى مطلع الثمانينيه
وعلى العكس من التصور السعد بشان النكبه
عامه 48 فان شلايم يقول ان فلسطين لم تفقد
في ذلك العام وانما في نهايه الثلاثينيات
او منتصفها حتى حين قضت بريطانيا بطريقه
وحش على الثوره العربيه والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه التي نشطت في وجه الاحتلال
البريطاني وحلفاء الصهاينه لدى شعيم كثير
من التفصيل عن الدوري البريطاني في دعم
الحركه الصهيونيه وانشاء وطني لليهود في
فلسطين على حساب الفلسطينيين فهي تاره
عملت مبكرا لتسهيل توافد اليهود من مشارق
الارض ومغاربها الى فلسطين وتاره اخرى
وقفت ضد قيام دوله عربيه بينما باركت قيام
دوله يهوديه في مكان المقترح يقضي بانشاء
الدولتين المتجاورتين
ذلك كله بالقول ان الفلسطينيين كانوا
ضحايا مشروع استيطانين استعماريين صهيوني
وتحالف مع مشروعي مشروع الامبريالي
بريطاني اما التحالف العربي الذي يواجه
الاصابات الصهيونيه في عام 48 فيقول سلايم
انه لم يكن لديه هدف او مشروع متفق عليه
بل ويصفه بانه كان ضمن الاكثر فوضويه
والاقل تنظيما عبر التاريخ خلافا لما هو
شائع من ان دوله الاحتلال واجهه قوه عربيه
موحده من سبعه جيوش تكتسب كتابات سلايم
النقديه اهميتها من كوني صاحبها يهوديه
عايش كثيرا من الوقائع المهمه في تاريخ
الصراع بين العرب ودوله الاحتلال والطلعه
على الوثائق المتعلقه بها بما ينفي عنه
تهمه التحيز كما يتهم المناهضون للصهيوني
عاده مشاهدينا الكرام نستكمل حوارنا مع
الكاتب والمؤرخ البارز افيش لاين في هذه
الحلقه الثانيه من المقابله فاهلا ومرحبا
بكم
[موسيقى]
ايوه
نفسي بانني عربي اليهودي لانني ولدت في
بغداد لاسره اليهوديه وكنا نتحدث العربيه
في البيت
وكانت ثقافتنا الثقافه العربيه
وطعامنا عربيا لكن حين بلغت الخامسه من
العمر
هذه الحياه المتقاطعه بين العربيه من
ناحيه واليهوديه من ناحيه كديانه
والاسرائيليه كنت تشعر بعقده نقص كونك من
اصول عرب كونك عربي في اسرائيل من ناحيه
الشخصيه فمساله الهويه اقلقتني كثيرا ومنذ
طفولته
الى اسرائيل وكان عمري خمس سنوات عانيت من
عقده نقص لانني كنت عربيا من العراق
بل يقولون انه تعبير متناقض
فان كنت يهوديا فلا يمكنك ان تكون عربيا
ولو كنت عربيا فلا يمكنك ان تكون يهوديا
ولكنني بالطبع لا اتفق مع ذلك
وجود علم فلسطين وعلم الاردن لماذا لماذا
تضع هذا العلم على يعني سترته
جدا بتاريخ الاردن
ولكنني ايضا عالم في تاريخ الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي ولا شك ان ضحايا هذا الصراع
وضحايا الصهيونيه هم الفلسطينيون لذا
فتعاطى فيه هو مع الشعب الفلسطيني
مشاهدينا كلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه الجديده
من المقابله وهي الجزء الثاني مع المؤرخ
البارزه
لاين هو من نخبه المؤرخين الجدد الذين
اعدوا قراءه التاريخ تاريخ نشات دوله
اسرائيل في المنطقه وقراءه الروايه من
جديد والحقيقه ان مسيرته يعني تعود بكثير
من الاراء المهمه جدا والتي يجب التوقف
امامها طويلا نحاول في هذه الحلقات ان
نقترب كثيرا من هذه الروايه ماذا حمل
المؤرخون الجدد من اطلق عليهم لقب
المؤرخين همم الجدد سلايم
ما الذي تضمته الروايه الجديده حول نشاه
هذه الدوله المصنعه في منتصف القرن الماضي
من ساهم في خلق روايه مزيفه حول حول
احتلال فلسطين احتلال الاراضي العربيه
الفلسطينيه ونشوف هذه
الدويله بروا ااه متكامله عبر هيمنه غربيه
ارتباطا ايضا مع المشروع
الكولونيا للاستعماري في المنطقه العربيه
بروفيسور مرحبا بك
سعيدين جدا كنا نتمنى نتحدث بالعربي لكن
انت تعرف العربيه لكن لا تستطيع التحدث
بها قليل قليلا تحدثنا في الحلقه الماضيه
عن كونك عراقيه عربي يهودي وعن هذه
المسيره الطويله اريد ان ابدا هذه الحلقه
بالمؤرخين الجدد والذين حملوا لواء روايه
جديده اولا لماذا اطلق عليكم لقب المؤرخين
الجدد متى بدات هذه الافكار تختمر بشكل
واضح وتظهر على شكل روايه تاريخيه جديده
همم تسترد على اسس علميه غير الروايه التي
كانت مهيمنه في السابق
توفا
اكتروسمان يفسران ظاهره التاريخ الجديد في
نهايه الثمانينات من القرن الماضي
احدهما كان السياق السياسيه الطاغي في
اسرائيل عقب الاجتهاد الاسرائيلي للبنان
في عام 82 حيث كان الامر جليا ان تلك
الحرب كانت حربا اختياريه ولم تجبر عليها
اسرائيل اذن الاسرائيليين يصنفون حروبهم
على نوعين حروب لا خيار لاسرائيل الا ان
تخوضها وحروب الاختياريه وقد احترف رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي انا الذكر
بان هذه الحرب لم تكن حرب الدفاعيه بل
كانت حربا اختياريه قررت اسرائيل اطلاقاها
وبهذا الاقرار الصريح انهار مفهوم لا خيار
والذي كان يحظى بتاييد عالم وسمح باطلاق
حوار ليس محصورا بشان الحرب اللبنانيه في
حسب بل حول تاريخ اسرائيل نفسها والحروب
السابقه التي خاضتها
وظهر جراء ذلك ان حرب السويس مثلا والتي
دارت في الخمسينيات كانت هي بدورها حربا
اختياريه ولم تكن مفروضه فرضا على اسرائيل
بل قررت اسرائيل الانخراط في تلك الحرب
بالتواضع مع قوه استعماريه عالميه
بريطانيا
لذا وا خلال الحرب اللبنانيه ظهرت حاله من
المعارضه السياسيه في اسرائيل
فكانت المره الاولى التي تظهر فيها معارضه
داخل اسرائيل بينما هي مخرطه في اذن حرب
وقد استمر هذا الحوار لما بعد الحرب
وتضمن طرح ناقدا لتاريخ اسرائيل
وقسمح ذلك لزملائي بان ندخل حلبه هذا
الحوار وان نتفاعل مع الخطاب الدائر كان
ذلك عامل واحدا اما العامل الثاني فكان
الكشف عن الوثائق الرسميه الاسرائيليه حيث
قامت اسرائيل
باستنساخ قانون التستر على الوثائق
الرسميه لمده 30 سنه ثم الكشف عنها بعد
ذلك
لذا فقد كان لي والزملائي فرصه الاطلاع
على تلك السجلات التابعه لوزاره الخارجيه
وزاره الدفاع ومكتب رئيس الوزراء بل وحتى
جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي
وقد كان عملنا ذا طابع بحث
مخرجات تلك البحوث التي اجريناها
حول الحقائق الموثقه
هذان العاملان يفسران ظهور التاريخ الجديد
ثم دار الحوار حول عام ال 48 حيث انتقدنا
انا وزملائي وبالشكل صريح
كافه الاكاذيب التي احاطت بميلاد دوله
اسرائيل
والحرب العربيه الاسرائيليه الاولى
فقد تم ايثاره ان اسرائيل صغيره الحجم
جابهت قوه سبعه جيوش منظمه لدول الجوار
وان خروج اسرائيل من تلك المعركه بانتصار
يمثل معجزه حقيقيه
بينما الحقيقه تؤكد ان عدد القوات
الاسرائيليه كان يفوق عدد القوات العربيه
ولا سيما في الساحه الفلسطينيه
الطبقه الاولى ان اسرائيل لم تكن الاضعف
وانه لم يكن هناك سبعه جيوش عربيه قويه في
مقابل جيش ضعيف او دوله وليد ضعيف انت
تقول ان بريطانيا بدات العمل في
الثلاثينات قبل قبل نشاه اسرائيل في 48 او
قبل حرب 48 ما الذي قامت به بريطانيا في
منتصف الثلاثينات في مواجهه
الانتفاضات الفلسطينيين كيف مهدت الطريق
لقيام هذه الدوله
في فلسطين من عام
1920 وحتى 1988
قام البريطانيون بسرقه فلسطين من
الفلسطينيين
ومنحوها للصهاينه
وحين اندلعت ثوره عربيه في عام
ضد بريطانيا وحلفائها الصهاينه قام
البريطانيون للصهاينه بسحق الثوره من خلال
استخدام وحشيه بالغه القسوه
وحطموها بذلك
الفلسطينيين بشكل كامل
لذا
فلسطين لم تفقد في نهايه الاربعينيات
بل فقدت في نهايه الثلاثينيات بسبب
الطريقه الوحشيه التي قضت فيها بريطانيا
على المقاومه الفلسطينيه
للجمهور العربي الذي يدعي ان ان فلسطين
يعني الفلسطينيين خسر والعرب خسروا امام
الصهاينه في 48 انت ترى انه الفلسطينيين
واجهوا اكبر قوه استعماريه في عام 1936
وان الحرب
والاحتلال بدا من تلك اللحظه وان هذه
المواجهه هي كانت المواجهه الاهم والاكبر
والاكثر وحشيه مع البريطانيين
المايكروتيك اوف بريطانيا
بل ازيد على ذلك في نقدي لبريطانيا ودورها
في نهايه فتره انتدابها
الفلسطيني والتي انتهت نهايه بائسه حيث ان
الروايه التاريخيه الصهيونيه تظهر
بريطانيا طرفا لعبا دور شريره
لم تقبل بفكره دوله صهيونيه
الفصل بموجب قرار الامم المتحده وان
بريطانيا شجعت حلفائها من العرب على
الاغاره على فلسطين بمجرد انقضاء الانتداب
وان يقوموا بخنق الدوله اليهوديه في مهدها
انا والى مبابي نقول وهي نظريه هو صاحبها
بل ذكرها في رسالته لنيل شهاده الدكتوراه
هنا في قسم دراسات الشرق الاوسط والذي
نشرها بعد ذلك ككتاب تحت عنوان بريطانيا
والصراع الاسرائيلي
1948 الف و 951
يذكر وانا اكدت ما ذكره بعد ذلك
بان بريطانيا قابلت بفكره الدوله اليهوديه
ولكن الذي لم تقبل به بريطانيا هو قيام
دوله فلسطينيه
بعد ان دعت الامم المتحده لقيام دولتين
يهوديه وعربيه
وكانت بريطانيا تعتبر ان الدوله العربيه
ستكون دوله تحت حكم المفتي
ومنح دعمه وتاييده لالمانيا
تحت حكم الحاجه من الحسيني على جزء من ارض
فلسطين الحسيني
هل الموقف البريطاني هذا الدعم للحركه
الصهيونيه مقابل الفلسطينيين كان مرتبط
بموقف المفتي والعرب في موضوع المانيا
والوقوف مع النازيين ام انه موقف اتخذ
مسبقا يعني قبل ذلك بكثير
الحسيني
مع الحاج امين الحسيني قبل عام
1948 بكثير وقبل اندلاع الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
وذلك لان الحاجه من الحسيني قاد الحركه
الوطنيه بينما كانت بريطانيا تدعم الحركه
الصهيونيه
الى ان اول مفوض سام بريطاني لفلسطين شديد
بريطانيا كانت منحازه ضد الفلسطينيين منذ
لحظه البدايه
كما يشار الى ان حجر الاساس لحكم الانتداب
البريطاني في فلسطين
هو منع قيام انتخابات باي شكل من الاشكال
ومنع اي مظهر من مظاهر الديمقراطيه حتى
اصبح اليهود يشكلون الاغلبيه لذا فلم تنظم
الانتخابات حتى اصبح اليهود يشكلون
الاغلبيه في عام 1948
على اكبر قدر من الاراضي الفلسطينيه
في وجود اقل عدد ممكن من الفلسطينيين
فنجحوا في اطار المفتي بانه هو الطرف
المعاند وغير المريض
مقتطفات من حديث لك في كتبك وهذه مساله
مهمه للجمهور العربيه لانه في صراع حول
هذه المساله تقول اثناء عمليه سحق
الانتفاضه كسرت بريطانيا العمود الفقري
للحركه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وبقدر ما اضعفت
الحركه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه بقدر معززه من
قدرات الصهاينه
تقول ايضا ان هذا الموقف البريطاني عائد
الى تيار عنصري
سفلي موجود في بريطانيا انذاك تجاه الحرب
وهنا يعني وهنا تقول يعني اورثت كلمه لتشل
وغريبه حقيقه الذي اصبح في ما بعد رئيس
الوزراء يقول لا اوافق على ان الكلب في
المعلف اللي هو الحق النهائي في المعلف
حتى لو قبعه هناك لزمن طويل لا اقر له
بهذا الحق وهذا موقف عنصري يعني في غايه
المشعه وايضا يقول مره اخرى لا اقر على
سبيل المثال بان ظلما كبيرا قد وقع على
الهنود الحمر في امريكا او ذوي البشره
السوداء في استراليا ولا اقر بان ظلما
ارتكب بحقها هؤلاء الناس لان هذه لافته
لان عرقا اقوى وعرقا اعلى مكانه عرقا اوسع
حكمه ومعرفه قد جاء واحتل
انا هم وبلادهم وهذا كان تشيرج اللي يبرر
موقفه من الفلسطينيين والعرب لان عرق اعلى
وعرق اوسع مكان جاء ليحتل هذا التالي كان
هناك موقف عنصري
متجددر في في في في الطبقه السياسيه
البريطانيه تجاه العرب والفلسطينيين ادى
يعني بشكل نهائي الى الى دعم الحركه
الصهيونيه على حساب الفلسطينيين وحكم
التاريخي في الارض
كانت المؤيده لليهود
والفقره التي اوردته عنه
هي من مرافعته امام لجنه بيل التي مثل
امامها في عام
والتي حققت في الحوادث المتعلقه بالثوره
العربيه
وهذا بالضبط ما قاله لهم قال لهم
الفلسطينيون عاشوا في فلسطين
وبذلك فقد شبه الفلسطينيين بالكلاب
بان عليهم
فهو يتحدث باللغه عنصريه فاقعه وهي لغه
صادمه بكل المقاييس ولكنها في الحقيقه لا
تفاجئني مطلقا لان العنصريه لازم
الامبرياليه
وفقا
المفكر اليهودي الامريكيه العظيم
فليس هناك اكثر من الاستعمار الاستيطاني
كمشروع امبريالي من حيث الوحشيه وتطرف
الحقيقه وان الفلسطينيين كانوا سيئا الحظ
جدا
انه مواجهه مشروع عن الاستيطاطا
مع مشروع بريطاني
وهناك العديد من الامثله التي تؤكد ان
الفلسطينيين كانوا ضحايا لممارسات
الامبرياليه البريطانيه
في عام
لا يزيدون
من الشعب
الفلسطينيون يمثلون 90%
الحقوق الوطني للاقليه
منع الحقوق نفسها عن الاغلبيه الساحقه
طفيليه في العالم العربي معجبه بالغرب
الديمقراطي المتسامح هي لا تعرف يعني
مصابه بداء الجهل فبالتالي لا تعرف هذه
مثل هذه الامور تعرف من الجيد ان مؤرخ
الاسرائيليين يقول هذا الامر
للمعجبين باسرائيل او او حتى ببريطانيا
العظمى التي كان هذا راي الرئيس صلاح
[موسيقى]
بموازاه الاله السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
المتمرسه والمتغلله داخل اهم اروقه الحكم
في الدول الكبرى لاعب الاعلام الاسرائيلي
دورا محوريه في تكريس الروايه الصهيونيه
في العقل الغربي
قبل ذلك افلحت الماكينه الاعلاميه
الاسرائيليه في تثبيت نفوذها عبر اختراق
وعيوب مخيله اليهود المنتشرين في شتى
اصقاع الارض من خلال جعله يؤمنون ايمانا
تاما بحق لا ينازعوا في انشائك يعني
الصهيوني استنادا الى روايات دينيه مزعومه
تعطيهم الحقه في اقتلاع الفلسطينيين من
ارضهم كان للاعلام الاسرائيلي الفضل في
تسخير قوه الدول العظمى لتفسير حلم كيان
الاحتلال على ارض الواقع وهو متضحا من
خلال الاسس التي ارساها المؤتمر الصهيوني
الاول عام
1897 حيث تم من خلاله رسم برنامج العمل
العام للحركه الصهيونيه لتحقيق قيام دوله
صهيونيه على ارض فلسطين وقد ظهر ذلك جليا
من خلال مقوله هيرتسل الاب الروحي والمؤسس
للصهيونيه الحديثه اذ كتب في افتتاحيه
العدد الاول من اسبوعيه الحركه الصهيونيه
دي وورد عام
1897 يجب على هذه الصحيفه ان تكون درعا
للشعب اليهودي وسلاحا ضد اعدائه وقبل
تاسيس دوله الكيان المحتل عام 48 عمل قاده
الحركه الصهيونيه على كافه المستويات من
اجل الترويج للخرافه الصهيونيه وتبرير كل
الجرائم والمجازر بحق الفلسطينيين والعرب
وبناء على ذلك شاركت المؤسسات الرسميه
وغير الرسميه كافه بدور اعلامي بغيه تحقيق
الاهداف القوميه والسياسيه للدوله لذلك
انتهجت اسرائيل منذ فتره طويله سياسه كل
مواطن سفير وسخرت في سبيل تحقيقه هذه
الغايه الاعلانات التلفزيونيه والنشرات
الصحفيه والكتيبات ووسائل التواصل والشبكه
العنكبوتيه من اجل تحسين صورتها على
الدواء
ما الذي فككه المؤرخون الجدد في الروايه
الصهيونيه التي كانت سائده ايضا تحدثنا
اولا عن دور البريطاني وان بدا من ال ال
الثوره الفلسطينيه في 36 ما الذي ايضا تم
مواجهته في الروايه الصهيونيه حول نشاه
اسرائيل واحتلال فلسطين
بتاعنا لسه في همم احدها ما يتعلق بميزان
القوه العسكريه في عام 1948
ولم يكن الامر كما مثلوه بمواجهه داوود
لجالوت
بل امتلك اليهود تفوقا عدديا
كما زادت امكانياتهم العسكريه تدريجيا مع
استمرار المواجهه في عام
يعني يعني بالعربي لم يكن مجموعه من
الضعاف والضحايا المساكين محاطين بجيوش
عربيه متوحشه كانت لهم الغلبه بفضل
بريطانيا هذه هو النقطه الاولى
ثانيه
للسكن
الروايه السائده
هي ما يتعلق بالدور الذي لعبته بريطانيا
بل هو العكس تماما
فبريطانيا تواطئت مع حليفها الملك عبد
الله ملك الاردن
لاجل ان يسيطر على الجانب العربي من
فلسطين اذا فقد كانت هناك حاله من التفاهم
بين الملك عبد الله والصهاينه وهذا كتاب
المعنون تواطؤ عبر الاردن الملك عبد الله
ولحركه الصهيونيه وتقسيمه فلسطين
[موسيقى]
مع طبيعه الاتفاق وهل هو اتفاق مكتوب
تجريمنس
من الاتفاقات السريه بين الملك عبد الله
وزعماء صهاينه اهمها الاجتماع الاخيره حيث
اجتمع الملك عبدالله السري
على تقسيم فلسطين بينهما على حساب الشعب
الفلسطيني
وقد طلب الصهاينه توفيق الاتفاقيه كتابه
ان كينيا
بقدر كبير من الحكمه رفض ذلك قائل لهم
اذا كانت الثقه بيننا موجوده
فلها حاجه الاتفاقيه مكتوبه
واذا لم تكن الثقه موجوده بيننا فلن تكون
الثم التقيمه الاتفاقيه المكتوبه اذا
فليست هناك وثيقه مكتوبه حولها هذا
التواضع اتفاقيه السريه ولكنني وصلت الى
كافه الوثائق الاسرائيليه وفي كتاب قمت
بتوثيق الاجتماعات الواحد والاخر وماذا
تمت مناقشته في كل منها وعامه
الوثائق الاسرائيليه هل يوجد مصادر اخرى
لهذا الاجتماع
بين المصادر الاسرائيليه وهي وبين الجانب
العربي وهي غير موجوده
ويقولوا هؤلاء النقاد ان ذلك يعني انه ليس
بالامكان الكتابه عن هذه الحقبه بناءا على
مصادر من طرف واحد
ولكنني ارد على هؤلاء بالقول كلا
فالمؤرخ يكتب عن التاريخ بناء على المصادر
المتوفره
وفي حال عدم وجود كافه المصادر فذلك لا
يعني مطلق عدم الكتابه بناء على المتوفر
من مصادر وبافضل الطرق الممكنه ومن جانبه
فانا اتبع المنهجيه نفسها التي انصح بها
الطلبه
لدرجه الدكتوراه حين يصلون الى طرق مسدوده
او زوايا مظلمه في بحوثهم فاقول لهم من
الافضل يجعله شمعه بدل عن الظلام
يعني من باب المهني فقط لان هذا الامر
يعتبر الطرف الاخر قطع سيكون موسي من باب
مهنيات يعني من باب الزاويه المهنيه نحن
نتحقق من هذا الامر كم عدد الاجتماعات اين
كانت تتم
بين الملك عبد الله واين الاطراف
الاسرائيليه بما فيهم جولد ماير
عبدالله
والاطراف الصهيونيه
لشؤون المستعمرات اميرا في عام 1921
ومن ذلك الوقت عقد عبد الله اجتماعات مع
زعماء صهاينه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
فباتت الاجتماعات اكثر تركيزا على ذلك
المستقبل
ومن بينها اجتماع بين جولدا مائير والملك
عبد الله
فما اصبح بعد ذلك في نهرين في عام 1947
وصلاه بعده لنوع من التفاهم
ان اليهود لن يقدم المساعده لعبد الله كي
يحقق طموحاته
ولكن عليه ان يقتنص ما يريد من ارض فلسطين
العربيه بنفسه
بانها لم تساعده
بينما لن يتدخل هو فيما تفعله اسرائيل
داخل الاراضي التي تتحكم بها وتديرها
لا شك ان عبد الله كان قائدا طموح للغايه
وكان من الواضح دابه في محاوله
لتحقيق حلم سوريا الكبرى
على الرغم من ان التفاهم بين الطرفين لم
يصل لقضيه سوريا الكبرى
كما ان بريطانيا
وفي نهايه عام
افضل بريطانيون للملك عبد الله الضوء
الاخضر
وقبل انتهاء الانتداب البريطاني بثلاثه
ايام فقط
وذلك في العاصمه الاردنيه عمان
بينما كانت الدول العربيه
تعد العده للاجتياح ولم يتراجع عبد الله
على الاتفاق الذي توصل اليه
لقد تغير الظرف
فحين تحدثنا في السابق كنت رجلا حرارا اما
الان فانا واحد من بين خمسه
والبريطانيون يمنعونني من ان افعل ما اريد
للقيادات الصهيونيه
فربما لم يلتزم عبد الله بحرفيه الاتفاق
الاولى
ولكنه لم ينفه ايضا
ولا شك ان هذه الخلفيه من التفاهمات
والاتفاقات
ادت الى حصول مواجهات محدوده جدا بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي والجيوش العربيه
كما ادت الى تجدد التعاون بين الصهاينه
والهاشميين في فتره ما بعد الحرب
وقد نشرت كتاب المعنون
وقد كتب الكاتب الصحفي المصري محمد حسنين
هيكل
مقالا طويلا عنه في صحيفه الاهرام
وذكر كما ذكرت انت استاذ علي
بان هذا التاريخ
مشهور عند القاري العربي
بينما يشكل جزءا في غايه الاهميه
انستقرام بقوله
انا معجب بك جدا
فسالته لماذا
فقال لان عملك في غايه الاهميه للقارئ
العربي
الذي يوجد فيه معلومات موثقه ودقيقه حول
التعاون بين الصهاينه والهاشميين هل كان
ثمه تواصل بين اطراف عربيه اخرى مع الحركه
الصهيونيه بخلاف الهاشميه
ديزاينس
وبركه
الحوار مع اي زعيم عربي
يمكنهم الوصول اليه
ولكن الزعيم العربي الوحيد الذي توصل معه
الى الاتفاق حول التقسيم من ناحيه مبدئيه
التي شاركت في حرب عام 1948
دي هذا اعرب كاندي يعتبر اسرائيل عدوا
ولم تكن سعيده بمشروعي اقامه دوله
اليهوديه مستقله على ارض فلسطين
اما بالنسبه الى عبد الله فقد كان الامر
مختلفا
اذا اعتبر ان اقامه الدوله اليهوديه
شرط اساس لتحقيق خطته هو
وبدون دوله اليهوديه تصبح فلسطين دوله
قائمه بذاتها تحت قياده المفتي
لذلك فمن نقاط الخلاف الكبيره بين اصحاب
التاريخ القديم
والمؤرخين الجدد
ان القدماء يقولون ان اسرائيل واجهت قوه
عربيه موحده
تتشكلوا من سبعه جيوش عربيه
يوحدها هدفان استراتيجيان
احدهما سياسي
يتمثل في تدمير الدوله اليهوديه الفتيه
والاخر
يتمثلوا في ارتكاب اباده جماعيه
وذلك بالقاء اليهود في البحر
شخصيا وعارضه تلك الفكره بان اقول ان
القوه العربيه التي واجهتها اسرائيل عام
48 كانت من اكثر الجيوش فوضويه
تنظيما على مدار التاريخ
حلفاؤه
وبذلك فقد خرج من هذه الحرب
اسرائيل والتي توسعت توسعت من نفوذها
ما شاء الله والثاني الملك عبد الله والذي
يسيطر على الضفه الغربيه وضمها لمملكتي
بعد ذلك
الجيش العربيه في مواجهه اسرائيل في 48 في
حرب فلسطين هناك روايه عربيه رسميه لا احد
يثق بها وهناك روايه صهيونيه ايضا لا احد
يثق بها ما هي روايتك افشلايم لموقف الدول
العربيه بعيدا عن الملك عبد الله الدول
العربيه التي واجهت هذه الدوله الجديده
ما مدى جديتها في محاوله
في هذه المواجهه
في عالم كوليشن
التحالف العربي الذي يواجه اسرائيل في حرب
عن 48 لم يكن لديه هدف او مشروع متفق عليه
وكان هناك الكثير من المصالح المتعارضه
ضمن ذلك التحالف مثل مشاريع قوميه متضاربه
وطموحات خاصه لممالك واسرمه
على العالم العربي
وكان فاروق يخشى من زعامه عبد الله على
فلسطين
في صداره العالم العربي
قبل انتهاء الانتداب البريطاني بايام
قليله
في الثانيه عشر من مايو عام 1948
كانت كافه المشورات التي قدمها مستشارو
فاروق للفلسطينيين
اذا فقد كان الهدف المعلن للجيوش العربيه
هو تحرير فلسطين ولكن في الواقع كان لكل
بلد من البلدان العربيه هدف يختلف عن ذلك
المعلن
فسوريا ولبنان
كانتا دولتان مستقلتان وكانت تساورهما
الشقوق حول طموحات الملك عبد الله حول
مشروع سوريا الكبرى
اذا فقد دخل الجميع المعركه
وهدفهم تحرير فلسطين في حين ان كل طرف من
تلك الاطراف المتحالفه
كان يحمل هدفا مختلفا تماما مما جعل الحرب
بعيده كل البعد عن مواجهه بين طرفين
وباتت عمليه سرقه للاراضي من قبل كافه
الاطراف
والزعيم الوحيد الذي نجح في الحفاظ على
شيء
من ارض فلسطين عربيه هو الملك عبد الله
يعني لم تكن حربا عربيه ضد الحركه
الصهيونيه لاستعاده فلسطين انما كانت حربا
عربيه عربيه
بداخلها الكل يريد ان ان لا تتشكل المنطقه
باتجاه يخالف مصالح وبما فيهم الملك عبد
الله الملك فاروق السوريين اللبنانيين وما
الى ذلك همم تقول بروفيسور انه التيار
المؤرخين الجدد قامه على اساسين اساس اول
اجتياح الاسرائيلي لبيروت في 82 وانه اظهر
لكم بشاعه هذا الجيش وهذه الدوله وتطلعتها
الاستيطانيه والتوسعيه والامر الثاني انه
وثائق بريطانيا ظهرت
اليس من الغريب ان تنسى في الروايه
الصهيونيه
بمؤرخينا اسرائيليين وليس بمؤرخين عرب
يعبرون عن
الضحيه في هذه في هذه الروايه يعني الغريب
ان مؤرخين اسرائيليين
جزء من هذه الدوله هم من ينسف الروايه
الصهيونيه ويتبناها
ويقوم على مشروعها
كان امرا صعبا
يت الحقيقه ان هذه ظاهره اللافته بالتاكيد
فالقدليه الحقيقيه لم تحدث بين مؤرخين عرب
واخرين يهود
بل كانت الجدليه ساخنه بين مجموعتين من
المؤرخين اليهود
ولا شكا ان السباحه عكس التيار
طالما كانت امر الشاقا
لم يعاني كثيرا مقابل ارائي نظرا لان مما
يحسب لاسرائيل
[موسيقى]
في السجن
المحكمه لو قلت روايتك في بلد عربي تعتقل
او تسجل لانك ضد الصهيونيه
بالطبع واصيب الناس بالصدمه
نظرا لانهم لم يسمعوا بهذا الكلام من قبل
شو فمثلا رده الفعل على ما تقدم به بني
موريس حول اشكاليه اللاجئين كانت عنيفه
فقد كانت الروايه الصهيونيه تقول ان
الفلسطينيين تركوا ارضهم وديارهم طوعيه
وامتثانا لاوامر اصدرها قادتهم
من يقول ان الفلسطينيين باعوا اراضيهم
لليهود وانهم سلموها طواعيه همم
هذه الروايه جمله وتفصيله
صحيح
وببساطه في التاريخ القديم يقول ان
الفلسطينيين غادروا طواعيه
بينما يقول مورس بين الفلسطينيين
وبالطبع فهنا كان نقطه خلاف اخرى تتعلق
بما جرى بعد الحرب
حاله الاختناق السياسي على المشهد الي
حوالي 30 سنه اخرى وحتى زياره السادات
للقدس ما دام الفلسطيني
الصهاينه تعودوا بكلمتين فقط التعنت
العربي
يزعمون ان اسرائيل
حاولت المستحيل كي تتفاوض وتتحاور
ولكنها طالما لم تجد من تفاضه او تحاوره
من الطرف الاخر
ولكنني خلصت في بحوث واحتمت على وثائق
رسميه تؤكد ان اسرائيل كانت الطرف المتعلم
بل زاد التعنت بعد الحرب
فكافه الزعماء العرب وعلى راسهم الملك عبد
الله وحسن الزعيم في سوريا وملك مصر دخلوا
في مفاوضات مع دوله اسرائيل الجديده بعد
الحرب
ولكنهم دخلوا المفاوضات بمططبين رئيسيين
الاول يتعلق بالاراضي في ما يتعلق بمصالح
كل طرف من الاطراف
طالما رفضت اسرائيل
بل كانت تسروا على ان ايه مفاوضات سلام
ينبغي ان تجري حول الواقع كما هو
من دون تغيير في الحدود
ومن دون عوده لاي من اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
اذا باختصار
فهذا الجبال الدائر بين المؤرخين القدماء
والجدد
يتمحور حول اتهام الجدد لاسرائيل
الوقوع في الذنب الاصليه
و منذ لحظه الولاده
وانا اضيف لذلك اتهامي للمؤرخين القدامى
بانهم يروجون لاسرائيل من خلال نظريه
الولاده البومه
من كتب في تلك المرحله يعني ادرك اهميه
هذا الامر هيكل الراحل الصحفي ايضا المصري
البارز ادرك اهميه ما ذكر
الجمهور العربي خاصه الشعب منها على هذه
الروايه من مؤرخ يهودي حول كل ما جرى
واعيد فقط التذكير ان هذه ان النخبه
المؤرخين الجدد ابي شلون
[موسيقى]
قضايا اساسي بدك تتحدثنا عن دور البريطاني
العلاقات العربيه مع الحركه الصهيونيه
وايضا كيف غادر الفلسطينيون وهذه الروايه
المهمه اللي همم بنيمورس انه تم اقتلاهم
من جذورهم بعمليات
وحشيه همم
شرسه يعني ادت الى الى خروجه من هذا
الاراضي شكرا
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام وهذه الاهميه
تكتسب يعني قيمتها الحقيقيه من اهميه
القضيه الفلسطينيه التي
نقول دائما انها تعرفنا حقيقه تعرفنا كبشر
كعرب على وجهك التحديد شكرا لكم المتابعه
لقاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع المقبل في حلقه
جديده من المقابله دمتم بخير وفي امان
الله
[موسيقى]